it's a week before Christmas and that
means father benjamin has a lot to do
the young priest from India is rushing
from one appointment to the next he came
to the congregation in bohol near
Minster six months ago I'll sushma mine
beans to hear anger phangan someone gave
me this bicycle as a gift when I started
here that was nice they said if you're
going to live in bottled you need a
bicycle and behold ugh broke too I'm
followed that was the first introduction
to life here in the Diocese a bicycle is
essential equipment and for the Catholic
Diocese of bow hold young missionary
priests like Benjamin Gaspar are also
essential father Benjamin now helps
father Raphael fans Raylan with the
congregation here in bohol father
Benjamin is still learning the ropes
conducting a service in German isn't
easy
but father benjamin has made good
progress father benjamin is 32 years old
he comes from chennai in southern india
he's a member of a missionary order that
sent him to behold the catholic
community here is feeling the pinch
there's only one full-time priest for a
community of 17,000
the catholic church in Germany has a
shortage of young priests that's why
they've turned to recruiting help from
abroad
is in sons globally we're networked on a
global level my booty the world is flat
to quote a book title yeah so the
Catholic Church which has always been a
global operation has to be a role model
in this respect isn't when stahma de
Beaufort Beulah tuft been aiming for
father benjamine it's been a major
transition everyone here speaks German
he's never had to bundle up against the
cold like this before back home everyone
is out on the street enjoying the warm
and sunny weather and the food is
completely different cut it cut it felt
that's it girl there's no curry here I
miss that in what we always have rice
with curry good the food is nice and hot
here the food is cold in India
everything is hot I lost most cases I
hot hot hot is good father Benjamin
stays in close contact with his family
they're proud of him and his missionary
work recently he went back to preside
over his cousin's wedding India has 28
million Christians many are poor the
congregation's young the church services
full there are many young priests in
India so his orders sent him to Germany
boyish care what a voice wherever I go
to work I have God's blessing he told me
that I was chosen to be a priest mind
Bluestar's a father Benjamin will spend
five years in BO hold the young priest
will take over more duties as his German
improves but father Rafael is also
hoping he and his congregation will have
something to learn from his young
colleague to dust oh my gosh owner do
you that's another nice thing about
having him here I mean father benjamine
can tell us about what church life and
pastoral work is like back in India
reminder pesto hi so we'll be able to
learn something from him to Lannan conan
father Benjamin says religion is still
more central to everyday life in India
he hopes to bring some of that here to
Germany
he's already won the trust of his
congregation he's a very nice and
pleasant man and he's very attractive
and good-looking okay sounds like fun
while he's around my age it's nice to
see someone at the altar who's in my age
group so to speak that's hard you know
father Benjamin is enjoying his first
German Christmas alongside his many
official duties there's also time to
relax and get to know his new flock over
a cup of gluhwein